all right guys it is f it is four
minutes till that intended direct i'm
just i have the chat hidden i'm super
hyped i'm trying to stuff some food in
my mouth like some greens you know
because i'm all healthy and stuff i'm
trying to stuff some food in my mouth
because i don't know how busy i'll be
after this anyway i'm gonna full screen
this oh i am so excited i am so excited
oh fine oh my gosh time are they early
are they freaking early oh no it's five
on the dot
come to me nintendo
what is this is this smash
are they starting off with smash no this
looks in-game
it's a monster hunter
it's ryze oh it's something new for ryze
oh my god what is that oh no i'm a
little rusty on my monster hunter
monsters well whatever it is it looks
like death itself
yeah monster hunter rise sun break if
you haven't played monster hunter what
are you doing if you have a switch this
is like one of the 10 reasons to own one
beautiful hello it's been so long hello
everyone i'm yoshi koizumi let's see our
first batch of nintendo switch headlines
oh that that wasn't part of it that was
not a part of the uh
yes
super mario party right it's almost time
to pause it's almost time i'm so hyped
for this game yes i'm here
so they are bringing bowser back as like
a horror land
as his old role being
i'm gonna buy it what is this a new rpg
welcome to voice of cards
[Music]
himself a hero he might not be he thinks
he is that's interesting i don't know if
i'm quite sold on that style of gameplay
but
it's interesting a spellbinding
experience oh straight up
from yokotaro
okay now you have me now you have my
attention for those of you who don't
know that's the uh genius behind the
near games and several others but you
know
well known as the near games um he knows
how to make a good game and he knows how
to switch up uh gameplay i don't know if
i'll buy more stories in hyrule really
they're bringing more to hyrule warriors
oh man oh man since this is just being
covered out with everything else i don't
know if they have a zelda section i hope
they'll have a cell dissection but you
know that's okay if they don't though i
mean i'm not really expecting much
ha
but we defeated calamity ganon
what's this then
what is this then is he teaching you how
to ride the motorcycle that's amazing
it seems hi i'm here for more more lines
of voice acting from all of them
amazing
hold up
oh this is like a this is like a
pre-story
three story
right because like there are several
discrepancies here already
it's gotta be
we're doing tr time travel again that's
cool i don't know what that is but
that's cool oh is that the shattered
chica slate what
what
i have so many questions
now this is hype
that's hype robbie's playable i forget
if he was playable before all this dlc
stuff but this is hype i'm here for all
of that and the new art chocolate final
fantasy characters
that's the cutest little gilgamesh ever
powerful there's no way
you can freaking fire people off of the
map
each racer also has a special dude this
is what mario kart didn't have the
gohonies to be
get him gilgamesh get him racist wow
exclusively onto nintendo switch next
year that is extremely unexpected from
me i don't know if you guys were
expecting that i was not expecting that
oh pretty good so far in our next video
we have some news about the last fighter
for the super smash brothers yeah yeah
okay here it is you guys it's time mr
sakurai the games director all right
reveal this fighter in the final oh
okay
okay
okay
all right i understand we have a date
you guys we have a date
oh what is this
what is this
what is this what is this
what should i recognize the birds
or the art style
because i don't oh is it pokemon
is it arceus
is it rcs
maybe
there's an animal crossing
i love that they had to talk about smash
before so that you would know this is
not something to do with smash
this is this is kirby oh my god
kirby in the forgotten land oh my god
oh my god it's an open world kirby
experience oh my god
look look at the platforming oh my gosh
look at all of this that's so beautiful
i got to see some power show me some
powers guys
powers link kirby yes
look kirby
i have a link kirby action figure i have
it it's right here like kirby yes
yes like kirby my dreams have come true
i've been standing you for so long
oh
what the heck
what is that
it's a giant mohawk gorilla mohawk zilla
get him kirby kirby never got
yes
he's coming guys he's coming
i cannot wait to play this on bandit
plays and cover this lies in store for
kirby did you see kirby's little freeze
frame face there
next we have this to show you
how man it hasn't even it's been 10
minutes
and they always save their big stuff at
the end
oh don't don't you play with me like
that
don't you play with me like that
what is that what is the kiosk the roost
okay so you so you can go up to the
roost all right
man i have not touched this game in so
long you guys
i feel like a fake fan watching this
huh
oh
wow an animal crossing direct
i guess it's time it's long
excuse me any players around the world
yes it has for a time freak more you
guys it's only been freaking 15 minutes
still i haven't picked this up
still haven't picked it up
enters the fairway ninja will also be
playable
take advantage of ninji's blinding speed
to outpace opponents
where is ninji from why haven't i seen
it before and why does it have button
nipples
amazing later today all right then
what's this oh an invitation
hmk is gonna have to flip in a magical
world oh mouse and dozens i thought it
was freaking kingdom hearts guys i
thought it was freaking kingdom hearts
oh i
i mean i think this game deserves the
old republic an actual remake but like
i'm i'm honestly okay with this today
like a nintendo wii it's been so long i
wonder if it's gonna feel exactly one
thing you must always remember
stay human
i haven't been presented with a choice
to leave being human yet humanity's life
but i'll remember that again
all captured on the switch it's actually
not while you're bad
it doesn't look that bad i mean like
i'm so happy about that
yes
yes here's my girl here's my girl
all right samus
ah for those of you who didn't know how
to spell dread this is how you spell it
no stop making jokes
your highest priority it should be
simply to survive this game looks so
good i'm so freaking excited
like two weeks out too i'm pretty sure
two weeks out there may be a very small
opportunity for this game
don't let your guard down
is that adam
is that the computer speaking
i'm pretty sure it is i don't know who
else would be warning her of anything
oh she looks so
cool
amazing
just a new trailer that's cool i don't
think any of that was new footage i
don't think
samus aaron the most powerful bounty
hunter in the galaxy you got there right
yesterday
i like this voice actress this game is
so gorgeous i don't want it i don't want
the channel
to hear it anymore that this game is not
worth 60 dollars are you looking at the
same game that i'm looking at how does
this game not worth 60
it's a full experience
it's gorgeous
and i want it to sell so well i wanted
to sell as well as it possibly can
stoked 100 of that it was amazing and
it's only been freaking 20 minutes about
nintendo switch online
okay
many people have been using nintendo
switch online since yes
because we have to team up
we honestly have dealership we'll be
adding a new membership plan
okay
as a part of this new plan's content
no
guys
nintendo 64 is coming to nintendo switch
online at a later time do you do you
understand how big this is pricing
information
yes absolutely bring it back
yes
i can't wait for the freaking scalpers
to take it from me it's okay i'll go i
ca i can settle for the third-party ones
oh man i'm gonna have to choose between
playing
for the 10th time we're metroid
oh man we still have 15 minutes y'all
there's plenty to play in these
collections oh i'm gonna die i was gonna
say this is an snes game uh my brain is
so jumbled after seeing nintendo
what are you talking about are you
talking about chapter two
you're
hi
yes chapter two absolutely
i'm already a little bit of the way
through it playing it over on bandit
plays
hey i like this remix of uh
root buster
so proud of deltarune for getting a spot
in the nintendo direct
so proud
look at the dancing puppos
get it peppos
[Music]
how's everything
there are still two big thumbs up
today i can't believe it i can't believe
it it's been oh
you absolutely can i love you you're
looking great he's looking great look at
the hair
wow yes i know who you are about the
movie right
[Music]
holiday next year okay that's great at
least in theaters oh my god look at the
art dude that's amazing that's so
freaking cool
that's like three days after my birthday
europe and other regions oh my gosh
that's so cool
this is so cool charles martin day
charles martinez first of all chris is
my brat
who will be played by chris pratt
but instead of charles martinez mario
will be talking a lot in the movie what
please next princess peach will be
played by anya taylor joy that that's
fine
that's a pretty good uh casting choice
chris pratt mario's little brother luigi
oh man early day oh man
i don't know how i feel about this
bowser will be played by the one and
only jack black
what
the comedian
michael key will be playing toad
i'm looking forward what is this is this
real life
is this real life even though this is a
mario movie donkey kong will also be
making is this real life i'm eager for
you to see a huge are we living right
now are you living right now what is
this and of course charles martinez
who has voiced mario and many more
nintendo characters in our games over
the years
is also involved
and will be appealing but you're not
surprised cameos in the movie chris
pratt is mario very collaborative i mean
he sounds illumination like me kind of
evolving coming it'd be like me voicing
mario that doesn't make sense
oh man it was gonna be a great birthday
present i hope it's still please look
forward to mario's adventure seth rogen
as donkey kong chris pratt as freaking
mario what the next is he gonna cheer me
up
are you gonna cheer me up
[Music]
oh splatoon
cool i still have never played a single
splatoon game i mean we've still got
more than five minutes left to hit that
40 minute mark seems to me like there's
gonna be one more thing one or two more
things that they talk about
oh hi
hello everyone i am convinced this is
not really studying uh man i'm gonna
have to be honest with you i'm
my vibes
it was it was kind of shot that chris
pratt is mario i guess it really
shouldn't get me down that much but he's
from story mode the single-player
campaign it's kind of getting me down
please look forward to more
splatoon 3.
i thought it was pretty good i thought
it was pretty good man i got kirby i'm
happy with kirby future okay this is the
last trailer we have to show you today
it's the last one and it's a trailer
it can't
be zelda
it's not okay i'm okay with that
i actually have no idea what this is
there's a dog there's a
final bargain huh
what is this i have no idea this doesn't
feel nintendo what is this like uh
xenoblade
this is xenoblade game
and ooh
splatoon 4
is it oh god i i uh i'm not sure what's
going on here
huh
what is going on
am i supposed to know about this
oh my god i should have known
oh yes you are we've been asking for
this game for
oh my god apparently
see that little wink she's looking at me
not you she's looking at me sorry guys
oh look at her go